keith en carrière avec nous au dr cary
bonsoir vous êtes à trois rivières
accueillez vous le cancer on sait ce qui
nous faisait le plus craint quand on
parle de délestage donnez-moi l'état des
choses aujourd'hui est ce que des gens
qui devraient être vus pour le sampler
santé qui ne le sont pas actuellement on
essaie de prioriser pour limiter les
dégâts on voit la plupart des patients
mais on est en est justement pour les
traitements parfois on retarde des
traitements on va changer les
traitements par exemple un spécial qui a
un adulte pulmonaire qui devrait être
opéré va peut-être avoir plutôt une
radio thérapie ciblée il faut pas penser
que ce genre de décisions vont être
prises en comité avec que des comités
d'experts plusieurs médecins il faut que
les gens comprennent que la vague
convient actuellement est beaucoup plus
intense que celle qu'on a vécue dans le
passé les hautes vagues beaucoup plus de
contagion beaucoup plus de patients
atteints ils vont même nous y menons
supprimer plus de spécialisation plus de
personnels atteints et isolé donc c'est
beaucoup plus grave lol comme on dit le
feu ait pris l'eau et qu'est ce qu'on
fait de 20 comment fait elle pour être
les meilleurs pompiers possible est-ce
que vous votre association les
oncologues vous avez des solutions en
tout cas des ddd moyen de faire qui
pourraient faire en sorte qu'on voit
plus de monde
écoutez on utilisait télémédecine on
travaille beaucoup avec les algorithmes
qui ont été développées lors des des
vagues précédentes on pense qu'on va
être capable de donner le service dans
mesure où mon manque pas de personnel
mais c'est sûr que le plus gros problème
actuellement c'est qu'elle l'hôpital
déborde de fassia si on veut qu'ils
devraient à être ailleurs qu'à l'hôpital
qui n'ont plus besoin des soins de
l'hôpital et ce2 qui viennent englué un
peu la machine et pour ça il va falloir
être capable de relocaliser ces patients
là vers d'autres sources aura-t-il mano
aux caisses importance que vous il ya
des gens qui sont encore dans les
hôpitaux des personnes âgées
essentiellement qu'on ne veut pas
retourner dans leur milieu de vie soit
dans les chsld et ou dans les rp ah bon
on n'a pas infecté célébrer raisons
évidentes
vous dites faut quand même les sortir de
l'hôpital parce que là il ya des gens
qui peuvent pas entrer qui ont besoin
d'y entrer tout à fait juste un exemple
très concret un patient âgé qui tentent
d'y fracturé le poignet besoin d'une
chirurgie mineure tester covit positif
parce que tester en préopératoire ne
peux plus retourner chez lui dans son
milieu de vie ans et chez celles des
noirs p o mais à ce moment à l'eau ce
patient l'on va rester à l'hôpital puis
là il va prendre la place d'une autre
personne qui aurait besoin de soins le
plus plus aiguë
je pense qu'il faut il faut être capable
de relocaliser ces gens là vers d'autres
unités on a dit oui dans l'hôpital qui
sont pas actuellement utilisé par manque
de personnel il faut penser aussi même
qu'on pourrait envoyer ces patients là
carrément à l'hôtel avec un encadrement
qui n'est pas médical on comprend ces
gens là ont besoin de personnes autour
d'eux pour veiller sur eux des aides
soignants par exemple j'ai besoin d'aidé
at risk parce que ma fille ait fait ça
durant la première vague déjà comme très
courte formation de quelques jours
celles auxquelles besoins plus criants
actuellement si on avait des centaines
d'êtres soignés ou des milieux d'être
des milliers d'êtres soignant on
pourrait aller vers des sites non
traditionnels à des hôtels ou des lieux
comme ça puis déplacé ses patients de
versilio l'eau et secourir des gens qui
soient viennent d'apprendre un
diagnostic de cancer ou ça fait un bout
de temps et là il devait avoir une
intervention qui a été annulé est ce que
des gens qui dont la vie est menacée
docteur karin mey
immédiatement non parce que toutes les
urgences sont fait immédiatement
et comme je vous dis tout un comité
d'experts qui va faire le triage puis
qu'il va faire la priorisation mekla qui
va avoir des délais dans les prochaines
semaines il va y avoir des délais mais
on devrait être capable d'éviter c'est
ce qu'on vise à vraiment éviter les
réversible pour tous ces patients
déclarent que les patients qui n'ont pas
de dépistage qui n'ont pas
d'investigation qui sont chez eux avec
des symptômes qui n'ont pas consulté ben
ils vont causer une petite vague qui va
durer des années au québec de gens qui
vont représenter des maladies plus
avancés qui aurait tué incurable mais
qui là ils vont est incurable à cause
des délais qui ont été parties on va se
passer là dessus mais effectivement les
chiffres montrent qu'il ya une baise de
il ya moins de malades pour certains
cancers vous vous dites attention j'ai
pas tellement qu'ils ont moins de
malades c'est qu'on les a pas de
diagnostiquer absolument c'est très
clair quand on regarde les chiffres de
2010 non je les suis à chaque mois on a
un déficit de diagnostic en absolu et y
est clair que l'incidence du cancer ont
pas changé dans population du québec
depuis 2000 dinars dont il ya des gens
qui sont à la maison malheureusement
avec avec le cancer qui ont pas été
diagnostiquée c'est pour ceux qui ont
vraiment besoin bail pour libérer la
capacité des hôpitaux qui reprend le
service au maximum dès que possible si
votre message qu'on a compris très
clairement le faut sortir des gens des
hôpitaux qui n'ont pas besoin d'être le
trouver des manières imaginative david
gentilles et nous parlait à laval on a
rouvert d'urgence un vieux chercher
celle des ce genre de moyens là partout
au québec merci docteur christian carrié
hématologue chef du service d'hémato
oncologie au sus de la mauricie et du
centre du québec merci nous avons parlé
mais ce beaucoup bon soir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit